what does it mean to have a Bitcoin many
people have heard of Bitcoin that it's a
fully digital currency with no
government to issue it and that no banks
need to manage accounts and verify
transactions and also that no one really
knows who invented it and yet many
people don't know the answer to this
question at least not in full to get
there and to make sure that the
technical details underlying the answer
actually feel motivated what we're going
to do is walk through step by step how
you might have invented your own version
of Bitcoin we'll start with you keeping
track of payments with your friends
using a communal ledger and then as you
start to trust your friends and the
world around you less and less and if
you're clever enough to bring in a few
ideas from cryptography to help
circumvent the need for trust what you
end up with is what's called a crypto
currency you see Bitcoin is just the
first implemented example of a crypto
currency and now there are thousands
more on exchanges with traditional
currencies walking the path of inventing
your own can help to set the foundations
for understanding some of the more
recent players in the game and
recognizing when and why there's room
for different design choices in fact one
of the reasons I chose this topic is
that in the last year there's been a
huge amount of attention and investment
and well honestly hype directed at these
currencies and I'm not going to comment
or speculate on the current or future
exchange rates but I think we'd all
agree that anyone looking to buy a
cryptocurrency
should really know what it is and I
don't just mean in terms of analogies
with vague connections to gold mining I
mean an actual direct description of
what the computers are doing when we
send receive and create crypto
currencies one thing worth stressing by
the way is that even though you and I
are gonna dig into the details here and
that takes meaningful time you don't
actually need to know those details if
you just want to use the crypto currency
just like you don't need to know the
details of what happens under the hood
when you swipe a credit card like any
digital payment there's lots of user
friendly applications that let you just
send and receive the currencies
without thinking about what's going on
the difference is that the backbone
underlying this is not a bank that
verifies transactions instead it's a
clever system of decentralized trustless
verification based on some of the math
born in cryptography but to start I want
you to actually set aside the thought of
cryptocurrencies and all that just for a
few minutes we're going to begin the
story with something more down-to-earth
Ledger's and digital signatures if you
and your friends exchange money pretty
frequently you know paying your share of
the dinner bill and such it can be
inconvenient to exchange cash all the
time so you might keep a communal ledger
that records all of the payments that
you intend to make some point in the
future you know Alice pays Bob twenty
dollars Bob pays Charlie forty dollars
things like that this ledger is going to
be something public and accessible to
everyone like a website where anyone can
go and just add newlines and let's say
that at the end of every month you all
good together
look at the list of transactions and
settle up if you spent more than you
received you put that money in the pot
and if you received more than you spent
you take that money out so the protocol
for being part of this very simple
system might look like this anyone can
add lines to the ledger and at the end
of every month you all get together and
settle up now one problem with a public
ledger like this is that anyone can add
a line so what's to prevent Bob from
going in writing
Alice pays Bob $100 without Alice
approving how are we supposed to trust
that all of these transactions are what
the sender meant them to be well this is
where the first bit of cryptography
comes in digital signatures like
handwritten signatures the idea here is
that Alice should be able to add
something next to that transaction that
proves that she has seen it and that
she's approved of it and it should be
infeasible for anyone else to forge that
signature
at first it might seem like a digital
signature shouldn't even be possible I
mean whatever data makes up that
signature can just be read and copied by
a computer so how do you prevent
forgeries well the way this works is
that everyone generates what's called a
public key private key pair each of
which looks like some string of bits the
private key is sometimes also called a
secret key so that we can abbreviate it
as SK while abbreviating the public key
is pk now as the name suggests this
secret key it's something you want to
keep to yourself in the real world your
handwritten signature looks the same no
matter what document you're signing but
a digital signature is actually much
stronger because it changes four
different messages it looks like some
string of ones and zeros commonly
something like 256 bits and altering the
message even slightly completely changes
what the signature on that message
should look like speaking a little more
formally producing a signature involves
a function that depends both on the
message itself and on your private key
the private key ensures that only you
can produce that signature and the fact
that it depends on the message means
that no one can just copy one of your
signatures and then Forge it on another
message hand-in-hand with this is a
second function used to verify that a
signature is valid and this is where the
public key comes into play all it does
is output true or false to indicate if
this was a signature produced by the
private key associated with the public
key that you're using for verification I
won't go into the details of how exactly
both these functions work but the idea
is that it should be completely
infeasible to find a valid signature if
you don't know the secret key
specifically there's no strategy better
than just guessing and checking random
signatures which you can check using the
public key that everyone knows now think
about how many signatures there are with
a length of 256 bits that's 2 to the
power of 256 this is a stupidly large
number to call it astronomically large
would be giving way too much credit to
astronomy in fact I made a supplemental
video devoted just
to illustrating what a huge number this
is right here let's just say that when
you verified that a signature against a
given message is valid
you can feel extremely confident that
the only way someone could have produced
it is if they knew the secret key
associated with the public key you used
for verification now making sure that
people sign transactions on the ledger
is pretty good but there's one slight
loophole if Alice signs a transaction
like Alice pays Bob $100 even though Bob
can't forge Alice's signature on a new
message he could just copy that same
line as many times as he wants I mean
that message signature combination
remains valid to get around this what we
do is make it so that when you sign a
transaction the message has to also
include some sort of unique ID
associated with that transaction that
way if Alice pays Bob $100 multiple
times each one of those lines on the
ledger requires a completely new
signature all right great
digital signatures remove a huge aspect
of trust in this initial protocol but
even still if you were to really do this
you would be relying on an honor system
of sort namely you're trusting that
everyone will actually follow through
and settle up in cash at the end of each
month what if for example Charley racks
up thousands of dollars in debt and just
refuses to show up the only real reason
to revert back to cash to settle up is
if some people I'm looking at you
Charlie Oh a lot of money so maybe you
have the clever idea that you never
actually have to settle up in cash as
long as you have some way to prevent
people from spending too much more than
they take in maybe what you do is start
by having everyone pay $100 into the pot
and then have the first few lines of the
ledger read Alice gets a hundred dollars
Bob gets a hundred dollars Charlie gets
a hundred etc now just don't accept any
transactions where someone is spending
more than they already have on that
ledger for example if the first two
transactions are Charlie pays Alice $50
and Charlie pays Bob $50 if he were to
try to add Charlie pays you twenty
dollars that would be invalid
as invalid as if he had never signed it
notice this means that verifying a
transaction requires knowing the full
history of transactions up to that point
and this is more or less also going to
be true in cryptocurrencies though there
is a little room for optimization what's
interesting here is that this step
removes the connection between the
ledger and actual physical u.s. dollars
in theory if everyone in the world was
using this ledger you could live your
whole life just sending and receiving
money on this ledger without ever having
to convert to real US dollars in fact to
emphasize this point let's start
referring to the quantities on the
ledger as ledger dollars or LD for short
you are of course free to exchange
ledger dollars for real US dollars for
example maybe Alice gives Bob a $10 bill
in the real world in exchange for him
adding and signing the transaction Bob
pays Alice ten ledger dollars to this
communal ledger but exchanges like that
they're not going to be guaranteed by
the protocol it's now more analogous to
how you might exchange dollars for euros
or any other currency on the open market
it's just its own independent thing this
is the first important thing to
understand about Bitcoin or any other
cryptocurrency what it is is a ledger
the history of transactions is the
currency of course with Bitcoin money
doesn't enter the ledger with people
buying in using cash I'll get to how new
money enters the ledger in just a few
minutes but before that there's actually
an even more significant difference
between our current system of ledger
dollars and how cryptocurrencies work so
far I've said that this ledger is in
some public place like a website where
anyone can add new lines but that would
require trusting a central location
namely who hosts the website who
controls the rules of adding new lines
to remove that bit of trust we'll have
everybody keep their own copy of the
ledger then when you want to make a
transaction like Alice pays Bob a
hundred ledger dollars what you do is
broadcast that out into the world for
people to hear and to record on their
own
Ledger's but unless you do something
more this system is absurdly bad how
could you get everyone to agree on what
the right ledger is when Bob receives a
transaction like Alice pays Bob 10
letter dollars
how can he be sure that everyone else
received and believes that same
transaction that he'll be able to later
on go to Charlie and use those same ten
ledger dollars to make a transaction
really imagine yourself just listening
to transactions being broadcast how can
you be sure that everyone else is
recording the same transactions and in
the same order this is really the heart
of the issue this is an interesting
puzzle can you come up with a protocol
for how to accept or reject transactions
and in what order so that you can feel
confident that anyone else in the world
who's following that same protocol has a
personal ledger that looks the same as
yours this is the problem addressed in
the original Bitcoin paper at a high
level the solution that Bitcoin offers
is to trust whichever ledger has the
most computational work put into it I'll
take a moment to explain exactly what
that means it involves this thing called
a cryptographic hash function the
general idea that will build to is that
if you use computational work as a basis
for what to trust you can make it so
that fraudulent transactions and
conflicting Ledger's would require an
infeasible amount of computation to
bring about again I'll remind you that
this is getting well into the weeds
beyond what anyone would need to know
just to use a currency like this but
it's a really cool idea and if you
understand it you understand the heart
of Bitcoin and of other cryptocurrencies
so first things first
what's a hash function the inputs for
one of these functions can be any kind
of message or file it really doesn't
matter and the output is a string of
bits with some kind of fixed length like
256 bits this output is called the hash
or the digest of the message and the
intent is that it looks random it's not
random it always gives the same output
for a given input but the idea is that
if you slightly change the input
maybe editing just one of the characters
the resulting hash changes completely in
fact for the hash function that I'm
showing here called sha-256 the way the
output changes as you slightly change
that input is entirely unpredictable you
see this is not just any hash function
it's a cryptographic hash function that
means it's infeasible to compute in the
reverse direction if I show you some
string of ones and zeros and ask you to
find an input so that the sha-256 hash
of that input gives this exact string of
bits you will have no better method than
to just guess and check and again if you
want to feel for how much computation
would be needed to go through two to the
256 guesses just take a look at the
supplement video I actually had way too
much fun writing that thing you might
think that if you just really dig into
the details of how exactly this function
works you could reverse engineer the
appropriate input without having to
guess and check but no one has ever
figured out a way to do that
interestingly there's no cold hard
rigorous proof that it's hard to compute
in the reverse direction and yet a huge
amount of modern security depends on
cryptographic hash functions and the
idea that they have this property if you
were to look at what algorithms underlie
the secure connection that your browser
is making with YouTube right now or that
it makes with your bank you will likely
see the name sha-256 show up in there
for right now our focus will just be on
how such a function can prove that a
particular list of transactions is
associated with a large amount of
computational effort imagine someone
shows you a list of transactions and
they say hey I found a special number so
that when you put that number at the end
of this list of transactions and apply
sha-256 to the entire thing the first 30
bits of that output are all zeros how
hard do you think it was for them to
find that number
well for a random message the
probability that a hash happens to start
with 30 successive zeros is one in two
to the 30 which is about one in a
billion
and because sha-256 is a cryptographic
hash function the only way to find a
special number like that is just
guessing and checking so this person
almost certainly had to go through about
a billion different numbers before
finding this special one and once you
know that number it's really quick to
verify you just run the hash and see
that there are thirty zeros so in other
words you can verify that they went
through a large amount of work but
without having to go through that same
effort yourself this is called a proof
of work and importantly all of this work
is intrinsically tied to the list of
transactions if you change one of those
transactions even slightly it would
completely change the hash so you'd have
to go through another billion guesses to
find a new proof of work a new number
that makes it so that the hash of the
altered list together with this new
number starts with 30 zeros so now think
back to our distributed ledger situation
everyone is they're broadcasting
transactions and we want a way for them
to agree on what the correct ledger is
as I said the core idea behind the
original Bitcoin paper is to have
everyone trust whichever ledger has the
most work put into it the way this works
is to first organize a given ledger into
blocks where each block consists of a
list of transactions together with a
proof of work that is a special number
so that the hash of the whole block
starts with a bunch of zeros for the
moment let's say that it has to start
with o 60 zeros but later we'll return
back to a more systematic way you might
want to choose that number in the same
way that a transaction is only
considered valid when it's signed by the
sender a block is only considered valid
if it has a proof of work and also to
make sure that there's a standard order
to these blocks we'll make it so that a
block has to contain the hash of the
previous block at its header that way if
you were to go back and change any one
of the blocks or to swap the order of
two blocks it would change the block
that comes after it which changes that
blocks hash which changes the one that
after it and so on that would require
redoing all of the work finding a new
special number for each of these blocks
that makes their hashes start with sixty
zeros because blocks are chained
together like this instead of calling it
a ledger it's common to call it a
blockchain as part of our updated
protocol
well now allow anyone in the world to be
a block creator what that means is that
they're gonna listen for transactions
being broadcast collect them into some
block and then do a whole bunch of work
to find a special number that makes the
hash of that block start with 60 zeroes
then once they find it they broadcast
out the block they found to reward a
block creator for all this work when she
puts together a block will allow her to
include a very special transaction at
the top of it in which she gets say 10
ledger dollars out of thin air this is
called the block reward and it's an
exception to our usual rules about
whether or not to accept transactions it
doesn't come from anyone so it doesn't
have to be signed and it also means that
the total number of ledger dollars in
our economy increases with each new
block creating blocks is often called
mining since it requires doing a lot of
work and it introduces new bits of
currency into the economy but when you
hear or read about miners keep in mind
that what they're really doing is
listening for transactions creating
blocks broadcasting those blocks and
getting rewarded with new money for
doing so from the miners perspective
each block is kind of like a miniature
lottery where everyone is guessing
numbers as fast as they can
until one lucky individual finds a
special number that makes the hash of
the block start with many zeros and they
get the reward for anyone else who just
wants to use this system to make
payments instead of listening for
transactions they all start listening
just for blocks being broadcast by
miners and updating their own personal
copies of the blockchain
now the key addition to our protocol is
that if you hear two distinct block
chains with conflicting transaction
histories you defer to the longest one
the one with the most work put into it
if there's a tie to
wait until you hear an additional block
that makes one of them longer so even
though there's no central authority and
everyone is maintaining their own copy
of the blockchain if everyone agrees to
give preference to whichever blockchain
has the most work put into it we have a
way to arrive at decentralized consensus
to see why this makes for a trustworthy
system and to understand at what point
you should trust that a payment is legit
it's actually really helpful to walk
through exactly what it would take to
fool someone using this system maybe
Alice is trying to fool Bob with a
fraudulent block namely she tries to
send him one that includes her paying
him a hundred ledger dollars but without
broadcasting that block to the rest of
the network that way everyone else still
thinks that she has those hundred ledger
dollars to do this she would have to
find a valid proof of work before all of
the other miners each working on their
own block and that could definitely
happen maybe Alice just happens to win
this miniature lottery before everyone
else but Bob is still gonna be hearing
the broadcasts made by other miners so
to keep him believing this fraudulent
block Alice would have to do all of the
work herself to keep adding blocks on
this special Fork in Bob's blockchain
that's different from what he's hearing
from the rest of the miners remember as
per the protocol Bob always trusts the
longest chain that he knows about Alice
might be able to keep this up for a few
blocks if just by chance she happens to
find blocks more quickly than the rest
of the miners on the network all
combined but unless she has close to 50%
of the computing resources among all of
the miners the probability becomes
overwhelming that the blockchain that
all of the other miners are working on
grows faster than the single fraudulent
blockchain that alice is feeding to Bob
so after enough time bobs just gonna
reject what he's hearing from Alice in
favor of the longer chain that everyone
else is working on notice that means
that you shouldn't necessarily trust a
new block that you hear immediately
instead you should wait for several new
blocks to be added on top of it if you
still haven't heard of any longer block
chains you can trust that this block is
part of the same chain that everyone
else is using and with that we've hit
all the main ideas this distributed
ledger system based on a proof of work
is more or less how the Bitcoin protocol
works and how many other crypto
currencies work there's just a few
details to clear up earlier I said that
the proof of work might be to find a
special number so that the hash of the
block starts with 60 zeros well the way
the actual Bitcoin protocol works is to
periodically change that number of zeros
so that it should take on average 10
minutes to find a new block so as there
are more and more miners added to the
network the challenge actually gets
harder and harder in such a way that
this miniature lottery only has about
one winner every ten minutes
many newer crypto currencies actually
have much shorter block times than that
and all of the money in Bitcoin
ultimately comes from some block reward
in the beginning these rewards were 50
Bitcoin per block there's actually a
great website you can go to called block
explore that makes it easy to look
through the Bitcoin blockchain and if
you look at the very first few blocks on
the chain they contain no transactions
other than that 50 Bitcoin reward to the
minor but every two hundred and ten
thousand blocks which is about every
four years that reward gets cut in half
so right now the reward is 12.5 Bitcoin
per block and because this reward
decreases geometrically over time it
means there will never be more than 21
million Bitcoin in existence
however this doesn't mean that miners
will stop earning money in addition to
the block reward miners can also pick up
transaction fees the way this works is
that whenever you make a payment you can
purely optionally include a little
transaction fee with it that's going to
go to the miner of whichever block
includes
payment the reason you might do that is
to incentivize miners to actually
include the transaction that you
broadcast into the next block you see in
Bitcoin each block is limited to about
2,400 transactions which many critics
argue is unnecessarily restrictive for
comparison visa processes an average of
about 1,700 transactions per second and
they're capable of handling more than
24,000 per second this comparatively
slow processing on Bitcoin makes for
higher transaction fees since that's
what determines which transactions
miners choose to include in a new block
all of this is far from a comprehensive
coverage of cryptocurrencies there are
still many nuances and alternate design
choices that I haven't even touched but
my hope is that this can provide a
stable wait but why style tree-trunk of
understanding for anyone looking to add
a few more branches with further reading
like I said at the start one of the
motives behind this is that a lot of
money has started flowing towards
cryptocurrencies and even though I don't
want to make any claims about whether
that's a good or bad investment I really
do think that it's healthy for people
getting into the game to at least know
the fundamentals of the technology as
always my sincerest thanks for those of
you making this channel possible on
patreon I understand that not everyone
is in a position to contribute but if
you're still interested in helping out
one of the best ways to do that is
simply to share videos that you think
might be interesting or helpful to
others I know you know that but it
really does help I also want to thank
protocol labs for their support of this
video this is an organization that runs
a number of different research and
development projects and if you follow
some of the links I've left in the
description to read into the details of
those projects you'll notice some strong
parallels with the concepts covered in
this video the challenges and benefits
of decentralization are by no means
limited to currency and to transaction
histories and the usefulness of tools
from cryptography like cash functions
and digital signatures are likewise much
more general for example a couple of
protocol labs projects such as IP FS and
vial cone Center on the idea of
distributed file storage
which opens up a whole field of
interesting challenges and possibilities
for any developers among you
protocol labs places a very high value
on open source so if you're interested
you can join what's already a very
strong community of contributors but
they're also looking to hire full-time
developers so if you think you might be
a good fit there definitely apply
[Music]
[Music]